he's trying for that head clinch you
See's trying for that clinch I don't
want to be in the clinch that's what
we're doing
okay but as I do that I don't want to
fight I don't want to fight him so we'll
go
slower I have to
yield my body has to yield wherever I go
I got to
Fit Don't Force away into into thing fit
inside you'll feel pressure I feel
pressure here on the inside I feel
pressure here right I feel my feet being
com
okay those those pressures are telling
you where you can go so that you can be
soft on this on this
okay so you feel that
right we go I fit inside I'm fitting
inside those holes there's a little
pressure coming forward so that tells me
where I need to
take so he he kind of feels like he's
give you air when he falls into that
okay so let's work on that try to
okay so what it's like your weapons work
see how I make contact with him I don't
wait for him to get there then I try to
Grapple this stuff out so I'm seeking
Conta it's like the swords touch and say
on the swords touch and then you feel
that pressure so he he never gets
here he's trying to get there he's never
going to get
there get there you just take the 90°
and you can't get there okay then you
make contact and move and then the arm
is
available contact move arm is available
it's different from you you forcing
something to
go contact yield arms
available in in his attempt he's trying
to get it do you see but he's out of
range you see that and now it makes the
arm
available
move of course you can see well the
stries are all
there arm available okay try it again
you try not to make things happen you're
doing woo way okay try it
uh don't try not to have your iido can
we I don't know what I'm going to do yet
okay I might want
try throw this way I don't know where
I'm going to go this is just no plch bo
just stand normal
stand so I'll give you something to do
so you don't want to take that come okay
knee St push the
head
fit okay try
[Music]
right so if he's if he's grappling he's
not going to have a lot of final
displacement I throw you already throw
him okay he's kind of like crawl
crawling in right so the energy is not
quite
there I kind of egging it on not making
it letting him touch me and I get kind
of there but see the momentum
stop there's little momentum to get here
so I want him to when I do this part
here I'm throwing him into that knee
so I don't want him basing now Bo his
that knee right there okay your lab's
under me cuz I'm going to do something
okay so let's work on first this
part that boom he hits the back the so
the back BL dries boom and gets him to
bend over to lower his head
more boom okay and he lands right under
me I 10
con and push his head first so he lands
right under okay let's try that he's
going boom notice how his arm is
straight so you have to re rewind how I
got there remember I want to be at out
Out Of Reach of his elbow power so if I
was here he'd anchor his elbow I'm done
so when I first move I have to be where
there's zero pressure that's out here by
the wrist okay that means his arm is
long when I take advantage of that so
his arm is long
okay not Not Bent arm is long here's
your here's one lock right there okay
and that's what's helped bringing them
down that elbow lock there and now now
what I'm going to do is use that long
arm to turn him there's no slack right
now you see when you bring this arm that
way his head wants to turn and that's
what I want if you have a bent arm you
got a lot of slack a lot of slack
without turning him so you want a long
arm here so I leave that arm
long and when I go here it's turning him
without me having to bring him up or
turn his head or anything the shoulder
lock is turning him and I just move out
and he falls now you're on Theon
belly okay so get in the right place
where you're out of his anchored elbow
that will expose his elbow that'll help
him Bend use that straight arm right
there to crank him down and he'll land
on the um belly okay all right let's try
the respiratory Meridian you can find
out by identifying where the flo ribs
are so they're not up here the the
bottom ribs of the rib cage that's where
your weight goes listen to his breath
okay that's what you're attacking so
when you drop boom that's what you hit
with your knees okay does that make
sense okay so we'll drop we'll slide
through the arm grab his head and bring
him into that kn
again boom boom and I know I drop
through that knee thread the arm pull
them into that knee okay let's try it go
slow and don't actually break the ribs
okay I'm just showing it okay now I try
technique
push my head through I'm not going to do
what you don't
do good here's that pressure he goes to
go ahead go okay so when I feel that
pressure I'm just going to move out from
under it he'll end up inside
control go for it boom you'll end up
okay
so I don't tap now I
[Music]
escape and I'm out
okay job n's job is to try for it okay
go one the non contestation so that's
why I fit in
there it's also one of way so that's why
I don't make things happen I let things
happen where they where they are that's
where I go okay so it's free movement so
that's this is where we were going so
that's why that's there and then he
starts to counter that I just build the
space you see I don't need to
uh the same way I don't have to make
something happen there and force y y
same thing I I go in the middle
rewind this arm is
there and it's telling me don't go here
you see that I go around the arm he
won't feel anything and it'll be on
before he would know it now as he moves
away I just fill the yin space it's
effortless
okay so look for that Yin space not the
Y there's the yin face boom boom see I
almost had it got a hold of him just
because I didn't push on him and then
you just fall into this space without
manipulating anything so what I mean by
that he's going to have a frame of some
kind you see that or I go around the
frame okay as he starts to get out of it
he's going to have another frame right
there so I go around that frame I'm
always going in the in
space okay try it
again and you can see that as I'm doing
all this stuff there's not really a
gap we I just Flo with him as he's
moving do do you guys got
that I want to feel
that
so
boom try it almost got it you see almost
got it without the strike right I can
feel his right Tristan you feel your
ribs they're right there now now he has
to really get out of it okay and then I
just fall into that there's no capap
that opens up there's no muscle tension
that's opening up okay so we'll do one
here here because there's no Gap I'm
going to
take this arm this arm that's here
that's the arm that I'm going to take
control of so I move it and I go for the
gift
route okay work that GI W
here so we'll work on that first
arm
boom I'm going around his energy so that
he doesn't push on me not doing this
right go around I try he moves I fall
into the space and now I go back to that
arm to push it across his face like
that swim in capture it you have the
gift wrap now okay so one more
time I'm not pushing on it here I'm
trying to go around it he gets out of
the way and now I come and push that in
across his body it's under my weight now
it's not perfect but it's setting up
incrementally then I seek control of it
over it come down to the wrist you can
push it in place now underneath your
body and you have a gift R here so you
have an arm isolation Okay let's work on
that arm first and as long as you fall
into the in space that arm will will be
there for you if you're tense and you
push you're going to have a delay the
arm won't be there okay try to use so we
already we already saw like at at speed
of life that this thing is on and it's
it's done okay um but as I said if you
like push and force things it's going to
cause a Time gap which will amount to a
a space Gap Okay so when he goes
out he can see how he pulled his
shoulder down you see that that that
happens because of the space Gap I go
here now oh too late but as you're
moving and he moves do you see how that
keeps his arm there okay but stuff
happens no big deal so let's say he he
pulled that shoulder all the way you see
that okay we clear that arm this way in
that corner
there right there okay and now we have
this arm moving this
arm so one more time how I did
that he's going to try to pull his
shoulder to the m well that that now
makes that arm
pinable okay so as he goes to do it
there's that Gap just smash that thing
on his body like that
normally he needs his frame
here but this time the elbows between my
legs cuz I went around it then finish
this don't worry what this is doing
finish the right arm pin by taking his
head and moving it towards his fist now
he loses leverage on the
elbow now this is easy he has his arm
strength stay at the distal end two on
one
and work the mirac
cor one more time I'm trying for my
thing he goes
under see where his elbow is put your
groin on that elbow finish the Trap this
is over by the time he figures out
what's
going okay slow on the lock quick on the
tap try it